-White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has been holding a lot
of press briefings lately,
but I don´t think all
the questions we need answered
have been asked,
so we decided to hold
another one
right here, right now.
That´s right --
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it´s time
for the "Late Night"
White House press briefing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♫♫
Sarah. Sarah? Sarah? Sarah?
Sarah? Sarah, over here. Yes.
Sarah, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders,
why do you think the country
is so frustrated
with the Trump presidency?
-It´s because
it should have ended yesterday.
-Yesterday. Great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What do you consider to be
your main responsibility
as White House press secretary?
-To create fake information.
-Okay.
What are the --
What are the five words
that scare Chief of Staff
John Kelly the most?
-The president
tweeted this morning.
[ Laughter ]
-What was President Trump
looking for
when he was putting together
his campaign staff?
-Regular offenders
that have been
in massive amounts of trouble.
-How is the White House staff
handling the new developments
in the Mueller investigation?
-They might start drinking.
-Let´s say hypothetically
that Donald Trump
was offered an immunity deal,
but in order to get it,
he had to incriminate his
two sons, Eric and Donald.
-He´ll take it.
-What´s Trump trying to hide
with that long tie?
-Probably a pretty big waist.
-So, today is Halloween,
and it seems the average IQ
in the White House
jumped several points.
Why is that?
-We have some kids
with us here today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is it true the White House
is putting Eric Trump up
for adoption?
-We´re not there yet.
We´re still in that process.
-What do you say to Donald Trump
to get him to show up
to cabinet meetings?
-There will be lots of fun
and I´m sure lots of candy.
-What does Donald Trump look for
in a spray tanner?
-An enormous amount of coverage.
-When does President Trump
change his pants?
-I think that any time
there is leaking.
-I heard Arby´s is looking
for a new slogan. Any ideas?
-All hat, no cattle.
-How´s Ivanka doing?
-Tomorrow is her birthday.
-Actually, it was yesterday.
-I don´t care.
-What did Melania
give President Trump
when she turned him down for sex
on election night?
-Inaugural balls.
-What would happen
if I shaved off my eyebrows?
-They will come back
stronger than ever before.
-I heard President Trump
sat on the toilet this morning
without tweeting.
-This is another important
milestone.
-Well, there you have it.
We´re out of time.
So, on behalf on the rest of the
press corps, have a good night.